hey youtubers is Charlie really cool
news if you guys didn't know there's a
new berserk anime series that I'm going
to be doing a couple videos for is as
many as you guys want and if you've
never watched it before you are in for
something special so just careful for
spoilers from episode one what I'm going
to do first is for people that have
never seen the series I'm going to
explain some of the backstory because
this doesn't start with the beginning of
the manga this is a series that's
adapted from manga it has really dense
mythology so if you're really into Game
of Thrones sagas that are really
hardcore with really dense mythology
this is like the perfect summer anime
and it's going to be airing weekly it's
24 episodes total it's streaming on
crunchyroll and it's only about 22
minutes per episode so it's a relatively
low time investment and I feel like the
funny part in all this is you know I do
like a lot of WTF videos is it almost
like every moment in this anime series
is a WTF moment so I might have to
change the way I do videos for just a
little bit from like the normal TV
videos that I would do is almost like
Game of Thrones if it were animated and
everything were cranked up to 11 like it
just got super crazy so here we go
backstory for the series so it's a
series set in medieval times where this
wandering mercenary takes up with a
group he wields this giant two-handed
sword it's almost kind of like this
christ analogy like he walks around
bearing the cross there's a lot of
religious iconography in this in like
Game of Thrones you have a lot of drama
between the characters like that's the a
story the B's story is like the larger
mythology and how they're involved in
the supernatural things that are going
on in the world
because as the series picks up in what's
called the Golden Age arc that's
basically with the title sequences for
this new anime you see all these
flashing images for stuff that doesn't
appear in the episode that's basically
them telling you the Golden Age arc all
of the story up to the point where this
episode one picks up there is an
original 1997 anime series based on this
but they retold that story in those
first three films and this is all
recapped in the title sequence so if you
want to you can go back and watch that
but you don't have to in order to
understand what's going on in this
episode they're pretty good about
explaining things like he explains that
the brand on him like at the end of the
Golden Age arc there was this really
heinous act where his former best friend
kind of transcends so that he can become
a
pasal of like the evil god of this world
or at least that this group called the
god hand believes is God so they gain
these crazy powers but in order to do
that he has to sacrifice guts and all of
his friends guts survives along with his
lover there's this really crazy event
called the Eclipse where Griffith
activates his powers and becomes this
dark apostle of this crazy God that you
don't really see in the series yet but
up to this point most of the series is
about the friendship of Gutzon Griffith
who develops this intense attachment to
guts as they travel together and work as
mercenaries but when he sees other
people admiring guts he has this intense
jealousy and he always acts out so even
though Griffith is kind of like the
villain of the story when this new
series picks up he's this really tragic
figure who came from nothing was kind of
trashed his whole life but rose through
the ranks but always felt like an
outsider and eventually is thrown in
prison his body is destroyed over a long
period of time guts and his friends
rescue him eventually but his soul is
crushed so he kind of gives this giant
middle finger to humanity activating his
dark powers sacrificing all of his
former friends to do it so now he
becomes the villain of the story so
that's kind of a gross
oversimplification but the Golden Age
arktech the stuff that precedes this new
series is the story of the rise and fall
of guts and Griffin's friendship across
all these wars that they fight in these
supernatural forces like the godhand
so his episode one picks up you're kind
of reintroduced to the characters you
find out that guts his lover who was
scarred by the Eclipse has gone mentally
insane he lost one of his arms like he
had to chop one of his arms off that's
how hardcore he is in order to save his
lover so now he has a metal prosthetic
that can also turn into a gun which is a
freakin badass and he still carries
around his giant sword now I can't
emphasize enough if you haven't seen
this series it is super hardcore like it
deals with really heavy themes but it is
really cool and really rewarding if you
stick it out the animation is OK
it goes with the computerized animation
that the film's went with it's not like
the original 1997 anime series so it
takes a little getting used to depending
on what your preference for animation
style is but even though in this episode
you really just see guts traveling
across the countryside without any clear
goal his ultimate
is to kill his former friend Griffith
who has turned into this monster with
these dark powers so the title of the
episode the branded swordsman is all
about the brand that he gets at the end
of that Eclipse event so the evil can
always find him that's why he explains
as long as the mark is worn the evil
spirits will always be able to find and
always be attracted to him so the world
he lives in is very dark he's accepted
that he has this really fatalistic
attitude toward it like everything is
futile but I'm gonna continue fighting
on he's a really extreme version of your
prototypical anime hero it's not so much
like the one punch character who's kind
of questioning where he fits into the
world he's like we know what do I do I
have all this power but what does it all
mean
guts is not like that he completely
understands where he fits into this
world he knows exactly what's going on
and what he's trying to do the elf
puck is kind of like his companion that
highlights the goodness in him despite
how crazy he sounds in this episode he
actually has a good heart
in the elf is just there to shine a
light on it like yet things are really
bad but there is still hope so he's kind
of like the soul of Hope in the story so
I don't know exactly how far they're
gonna take this story into the manga but
what I'm expecting from the next couple
of episodes is them to just continue
world building in this post Eclipse
world the real story as you can imagine
is like you know we'll guts ever be able
to find happiness will he ever be free
of the mark free of the demons will be
able to help his former lover will he
either kill his friend Griffith or will
he restore him because you know right
now he's like this mutated apostle of
this crazy God so you have one or two
options there you can kill them or you
can bring him back just like Game of
Thrones this is one of those series
that's adapted from manga so you can
read ahead if you want you can learn
what happens I think this anime is going
to be fairly faithful to that story so
if you do want to read a hit like if you
really like to do that then you can
totally go out and search for the manga
but the story that the new episodes are
telling is not story that they've done
before like in the previous anime or in
the previous OVA films so I'll say you
know probably just my favorite moment
from the episode is the demon tree
coming to life in eating those other two
bandits that were originally trying to
kill guts like the story they tell is a
good example for how deep the mythology
is like I used to hear they would nail
people's guts to this tree and then make
them run around
so you see all these nails in the tree
but then later you see like the entire
tree come to life and just eat them both
and consume their souls so not for the
faint of heart but if you do stick it
out it's actually a really rewarding
story so let me know what you guys
thought of the episode and let me know
if you want me to do weekly videos but
I'm happy to explain any of the more
dense concepts or characters or any of
the backstory that you guys want so be
sure to subscribe to get everything just
let me know what kind of berserk things
that you guys want me to talk about like
if you just want me to do episode videos
or if you want me to explain specific
concepts the new episodes post each
Friday so that's probably when my videos
will post to the post like Friday night
or Saturday morning or something like
that so be sure to check it out get hype
once I get a little bit deeper into it
I'll make a playlist just for berserk
videos but until then I'm just going to
jam this in the normal playlist with all
the other videos so while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for all my Game of Thrones Season 7
predictions and you can click here to
learn about what I think is going on
with the flash season 3 villain thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you